I remember my dad told me one day we
were painting the house and then he said
he's like I'm doing this so you and your
sister never have to be around pay like
this again do you feel that all things
according to Paris when you're going
into this career I feel like I
disappointed my dad I don't want to talk
about that right now we're about to go
pick up a furniture piece it's gonna be
a royal blue I like to have like want to
come out it fit like everything I
usually like spray the foam on top of it
and then I spray painted or I like
little objects
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
my mom she was trying to like escape the
horrible like living condition or she
was father she had to cross the desert
to get here she she would always tell us
that she like lived in Skid Row for a
few months when she first got here and
she said that for her to like survive
she had to go to a McDonald's dumpster
and like pick up the food and eat that
until she found like someone that was
gave her a job at a bar I really
experienced it when I was like older
like 14 and I went to Mexico and I
showed up with like my clothes that I
mean that I had here and then I went
there and I was like not everyone gets
to have what I have
[Music]
I feel like they're sort of like this
pressure with like children of
immigrants who like get into like
money-making career because like you
come from nothing your parents did all
that so you'd have to do the same that
they're doing you know my mom was really
supportive like all the time was like
what I wanted to do my dad was more like
realistic and was like hey like you need
to like do something that's gonna make
money so you should just like be a
nervous and I was like it would have
been easier if I just wanted to be at
the nurse everything is already set for
me but like as an artist you never know
where the opportunities are gonna come
do you feel like your mom is ever
disappointed about it I don't think so I
think she sees all the potential I got
makes me like a lot happier hopeful that
okay if she sees something in me then
like I can totally do it
[Music]
[Music]
I mean a lot of us have the same story
you know we have immigrant parents and
we're like doing something that it's
like they don't understand what we're
doing it because that's what we love
you've literally got all the odds
against you I mean most of the galleries
are like wide run or his people that
come for money and it's like they get to
pick and choose who they want to put so
now if they wanna like you know have
like diversity they start adding people
like us that's was anything here who
runs must eat who runs BuzzFeed BuzzFeed
is giving me the opportunity to talk
about my stuff right now but what if
this person didn't want that happening
and that's what anything
[Music]
[Music]
if you could say something to your
seventeen-year-old self what would you
say how to stop
odds are already against you might as
well just [ __ ] do them sorry I don't
want to cry camera
[Music]
I tell myself eventually it's gonna be
all worth it
[Music]